what is this laguna beach hello
good afternoon this is alana calling
from the lofts at montana beach
how are you i'm great how are you
good we are just calling to say that
we received an email and trying to make
a reservation for you tonight
um and we were wondering if 5 45 would
be alright with you
unfortunately we we can't uh come
the couple that was going to come to
have dinner with us
unfortunately uh has you know been in a
car accident and they've been horribly
mangled
oh yes um
so should i cancel that for you
i mean i may still go do you have the
rotisserie chicken right
sorry you have the rotisserie chicken
still on that menu
i believe we do and that's good that
chicken's good if you had it with the
fava beans
um let's see
[Music]
yes we still do have our rotisserie
chicken okay so you know we're gonna
find another couple can we do four at
five pm
four at five pm yes thank you so much
it's very sad what happened but they
weren't a fun couple anyway
right it all works out for the best
i guess doesn't it always yeah
thank you dear four and five
yes all right